i i do want to cover the f1 thing
because it was such a
yeah i need you to explain to me what
exactly happened there there is so so
many people talking about it there is so
much context i'm gonna do the best to
say this within a couple minutes um all
of you f1 nerds before you start [ __ ]
projecting these opinions and [ __ ] onto
me i'm just gonna try to give this even
so i don't give a [ __ ] what you think
should have happened just shut up okay
jeez
no you have to be that way because f1
fans are the most argumentative
gatekeeping they're so annoying okay
so
uh
in formula one
at a baseline you should understand that
there are a lot of they're crashing is
very
it's just sick yeah okay
it's it's bound to happen okay so the
procedure for that is what's called a
safety car okay and typically that they
have two versions one that's virtual
which is this is kind of sick just like
from a technology standpoint it just
tells them in their steering wheel this
is a virtual safety car and they put
their speed down
and like they
run the track at 40 speed um and it's
just kind of crazy that they can
i don't know issue rules and stuff like
that specifically i see like they do
that in order to
navigate whatever wreckage is on the
yeah and it's to clear it out or
something yeah so typically
virtual is issued if like
someone hits a curve and then like a
[ __ ] carbon fiber piece like lands in
the middle of the track and if it's like
a high speed area of the track or
something it's like hey slow down
a marshall is gonna just hop over the
fence run out grab that piece and we're
back to racing okay so then full safety
car is when the crash is really bad
and they have a car actually get out in
front and lead the cars um
so that i guess it's to sort of like
control the pace of the cars and make
sure something whatever
doesn't happen
okay now you know that
so
the context of this season
was really intense because there were
rule changes and mercedes is dominated
for seven years and then in this year
red bull was actually like challenging
for it in a very convincing way this kid
max verstappen
he came into formula one at 17 years old
he's a [ __ ] demon
uh
he's just been putting up wins and it's
like for the first time he's showing
that
someone can possibly beat lewis hamilton
he drives for red bull he drives forever
okay yeah
and max does not louis yeah okay and
there are people that put an asterisk
next to lewis because like there's one
championship where a dude
crashed out and it changed the points
structure and he took a championship
from another person blah blah blah
whatever i don't care
um so going into this season it's been
really tense there was a big crash in in
the british grand prix um that was
really controversial there's another one
in italy that was really controversial
and
um going into this it was like the
perfect storm because
it ended up being that they were on
[ __ ] even points
so
you know it's literally winner takes all
really yeah
okay and this has what is the
championship or what's like the
trophy there's two championships um
drivers individually are awarded points
for like first first through tenth place
yeah so there's the world drivers
championship where you've as a driver
you've won the most points out of the
season and this was the last race this
is the very last race yeah then there's
the constructors where as a team you've
won the most points okay
so
going into this for the world drivers
championship
this is the it's even points for lewis
and max
and the speculation is that lewis wanted
to end it here because next year starts
a whole new era of construction of
formula one car and people are thinking
he wanted to get the eight beat michael
schumacher's record and then just be out
um
so
it was really tense
all right so now the context of the race
is this
um the mercedes car
was showing to be a [ __ ]
like rocket ship it was so [ __ ] fast
um
in the qualifying round max verstappen
happens to just
clinch the first place spot so he's
starting in
first place on the grid and then lewis
is on second place
and
historically whoever has the first place
grid slot from qualifying wins the race
okay um so max had the first max had it
first so it's looking good because
everyone was worried oh is the red bull
car fast enough to compete with the
mercedes car this year and if max was
able to oust louis in qualifying surely
there's a chance
so
uh the race starts and lewis [ __ ]
bolts he just he's gone and they go into
this turn
and it was really controversial because
max
he dives down on an opening and he makes
the move within the
the limits of the track but lewis goes
off and he cuts the corner and stays in
front so max is now on radio being like
hey he needs to give me the position
back i
i took it from him fairly within the
limits of the track he needs to issue it
back to me
and the referees basically
they tell red bull no he doesn't because
lewis slowed down
and whatever he gained from that
uh whatever advantage was given back so
max is within
what you know the distance he was within
prior to that move
um it didn't matter because
lewis goes on to put [ __ ] 10 seconds
of a gap ahead of max
so he's leading the race um and it's not
looking like red bull really has a shot
so
um
max pits early to because he he was on
like a faster set of tires which
basically just means the car moves
faster so he pits for a different set to
try to like it's a longer lasting set of
tires so like maybe
when lewis has to pit later in the race
max will can like make up some time
there now it's just coming down to like
race strategy this is the part this gets
confusing so [ __ ] all this
um
there is a moment like about midway
through the race where max's teammates
he stays out so he doesn't pit
lewis pits now louis you know is coming
from like fourth place trying to reclaim
first and max is down in like sixth or
seventh and he's you know whatever
trying to catch up to louis so now red
bull is doing like this pincering thing
where as lewis is approaching first
max's teammate is slowing down and like
putting up a battle so now lewis doesn't
have clean laps because he's trying to
get around sergio
um
sergio does an insane job and reduces
the gap between max and lewis to [ __ ]
one and a half seconds which is insane
it went from 12 to one and a half
so now max seems like he has a fighting
chance but [ __ ] again
the mercedes car is on fire and you know
lewis takes off there's a point where
the gap is 17 seconds um
and
uh
with six laps left to go
this kid nicholas latifi is canadian
yeah
he [ __ ] i finally started listening
to the story
i'm really interested in this so keep
going so
six laps left louis it's looking like
he's definitely gonna take this home
um nicholas
he gets into what's called like the
dirty air and the thing about formula
one cars is they move so fast that
they're like airplanes and they displace
the air behind them so
if you're a car coming up behind and
you're in the dirty air the air is
literally turbulent so the car
performance is [ __ ] unpredictable
because like the whole chassis is
fighting air yeah
nicholas tv gets in the dirty air and he
spins and he [ __ ] crashes
so
uh
max has track position and he
he pits for a new set of soft tires
louis's tires are like 30 some laps old
so
max is gonna have crazy grip
the thing i forgot to mention is you can
pit
during a safety car it's like a cheap
pit stop okay a pit stop on average
takes like 24 seconds if you do it under
a safety car it only cost you like 17 or
something [ __ ]
all right so you need to know all that
so you can understand like this final
lap so
lewis doesn't pit because if he pits he
would have came out behind max so he has
to stay out on these old tires
and
uh formula one cars they naturally the
faster cars lap the other cars so it
creates a lot of like weird grid order
because two cars can be like first and
second but cars in between them can be
in this case like positions four through
five or six and seven
so
max pitts he comes out and he's behind
like five cars who was the one who
crashed by the way nicolas latifah okay
that's the canadian guy he has canadian
yeah yeah alright i got it sorry so
whatever so
um
the safe of a safety car comes out and
it's leading the cars which means you
know uh it's looking like the race is
gonna end under a safety car okay and
mercedes is thinking okay
this is fine um
uh
whatever like we're gonna win um but
randomly
uh
so all the because they think they're
gonna win because the referees told
everyone
no one can unlap themselves so that
means max has to stay behind the five
cars and even on the off chance that
they go racing for like one or two more
laps he still has to get through those
five cars to catch up to lewis
the cars are rolling around track and
on these like
they're on the like the lap before the
last one
suddenly the fia who was like they're
like the refs they make a call on radio
and say nope left cars can unlap
themselves
and then mercedes is like wait what the
[ __ ] like you can't do that you
literally just said like you're
basically like reversing the call you
made so that
enables max to jump the five cars so now
he's on
a fresh set of tires
he is
side by side with lewis who is on 30 old
you know tires that are 30 laps old
and um when a safety car resumes you
can't use something called drs which is
like it's like a little turbo boost it's
like the wing position changes and the
car can like catch up i know this is
like really [ __ ] long but basically
they [ __ ] trigger the one lap left of
racing and max has brand new tires so of
course he's gonna smoke louis and he
[ __ ] takes the win
and he takes the world championship
despite not having led the race
for 50
one and a half laps
so the whole thing felt like it's this
season that had so many points of
controversy
so many like you know oh uh it could go
like this it could go like that
and it comes down to this moment where
it feels like the refs just kind of look
around and go
yeah just
give it to red bull yeah just yeah and
what what made it like what added insult
to injury is
you know lewis is like the first you
know
really successful black formula one
driver ever
and uh that's why he like you know he is
such a special guy in a field that is
like dominated really by just like you
know
other people
and um
what was really kind of gross was how
many people came out and were like i'm
really glad michael schumacher's record
wasn't broken
like that's what they took from the
whole thing uh it's like ugh you
that's what you got from that right you
didn't want lewis to have it like why
not yeah it's pretty crazy if he does
right
um
and uh so yeah i think it just
it stained what could have been a very
legit
uh
ending you know yeah um
so is it legal to like reverse a call
like that
technically it is i guess it's it's it's
what comes down to why they make that
call like why would so the joke is that
the fia or like the refs and people
always spell it
like they prefix it with ma so it's
mafia
so a lot of people feel like
tony was up there yeah a lot of people
feel was it was sucked it was tones yeah
and he's like
i like red bull
don't you let rebel basically pick up
the phone and reverse that call huh yeah
yeah that's those those are people's
feelings yeah okay yeah i'm sure i
missed some things in there and someone
will tell me i got something wrong or
whatever but
the gist of it is that
on on paper
max
was never really leading the race
wow okay yeah
so it's rigged
that's like that's the other complaint
is people are like okay if you want to
reverse calls that's fine but like
it's so wildly inconsistent how does
anyone even ever want to watch this
again because it's like literally up to
you guys how you guys want it to go
um then other people are joking that you
know netflix put in the call so that
they could have a really dope drive to
survive season
yeah
yeah so
it's uh
yeah
it's
it's ugly damn that thank you thank you
for describing that yeah and i'm sorry i
no no i needed to know
it was a pretty frustrating thing i woke
up at [ __ ] five
yeah i saw
i like you know what i mean like i woke
up from doing those shows to watch that
horse [ __ ] i was like this is a joke man
i [ __ ] woke up at 5 a.m for this
[ __ ] literally man
literally but i guess raps are [ __ ]
in every sport so
i just think it's uh
maybe the raps are dutch
i know the guy the guy's name is michael
massey and
i would be afraid to go outside if i was
that dude why
oh just because oh so many people are
probably
i mean everyone english hates him now
because of that call or because of other
i mean all season he's been a little bit
and he's had questionable moments but i
think
that one you know yeah because all you
know a lot of english fans are for lewis
and you know they
they saw that and it's it's off with
your [ __ ] head
if we see you in [ __ ] london we're
gonna cut your [ __ ] head off like
he's a dead man yeah yeah
he's [ __ ] he needs to buy a new face
[Laughter]
which he probably can yeah that mafia
money yeah yeah literally yeah he's
getting slipped yeah yeah
[ __ ] listen i like the taste of red
bull yeah i like that stuff keeps me
awake
once you make the call
you